uh we'll see in a second i guess okay
the move has been taken back what's it
going to be
is that a king's pawn d4 i think that's
e4 oh that's e4 oh wow all of our
predictions
are wrong with the opening unfortunately
wow it's a king's pawn opening and
how will napoleon actually react big
moment
it's e5 no sicilian okay so they're like
switching the colors because magnus with
black against dion it was e4 e5 so now
now we see magnus playing for with white
it's always
nice to see new new openings being
played so this is so far the same as in
game three uh yeah until this last move
uh janna pogba she now has just played
copycats and it's the petrov defense i
wonder how many people would have
guessed this because uh napoli actually
not known for this opening uh he played
it a couple of times i think in the
candidates tournament earlier this year
but that was really the first time we've
seen it from him
and uh it's not traditionally his style
either just to play kind of a drawish
kind of solid opening
and okay magnus is going to pawn up
temporarily uh but white's knight having
grabbed the opponent gets kicked back
and the pontiac will regain his pawn so
this is well known staff and arya and
this this happened a lot right in the
match between castle and caruana in
2018. yeah this is the petrov and it's
known to be like the most solid openings
in chess but but as uh david said it's a
bit surprising that jan plays it because
he it's not usually his style he plays
like he played like sicilian his whole
life he's known to be an aggressive
player but for for the match it's uh
probably a good strategy it's
interesting i was talking to anish like
two months ago and we were discussing
which opening jan will go for after e4
and i was thinking the sicilian but
anish actually predicted that jan will
go for the petrov
and i was surprised that he he said that
but he was actually actually right spot
on yeah anishkuri clearly uh yeah i can
see the future so meanwhile a couple
more moves
both sides just occupying the center
with pawns bringing bishops out this is
still very very standard stuff and uh
okay i wonder who will launch the first
surprise because i think magnus avoided
this exact position uh in his match
against caruana he was trying different
lines of the petrol or against the
petrov as white okay both sides now just
castling their kings
still very traditional
very well-known territory here yeah
other moves might include just bringing
the rook okay he does go for your uh
your suggestion now this is the most
popular reply yeah because then magnus's
team will have to have studied a lot the
berlin have some ideas in that yeah
especially the berlin that will take
weeks to study just to come up with a
few ideas so um i wonder how much time
magnus and his coaches devoted to this
opening and there we go ariana is
correct black does bolster his pawn
center with a move c6 and mikey
is awesome the sky is blue guys back to
you like david says uh highlighting the
consequences now i'm smiling because
this appears to be magnus's like
strategy on the database is actually a
game between lavon aronian and arjun
erigaisi one of the competitors on the
melt were the champions chester only 16.
and there levon played in a very
committed way he pushed his pawn forward
magnus has gone for a little bit more
flexible move and developed knight okay
we do have another move a quick one from
janupogniacci trade of knights now there
will be some exchanges i think white is
about to capture the bishops okay the
bishops are about to come off the board
and then i think magnus will just
recapture the night and continue putting
pressure with his queen against some
weak pawns
all right well let's head down to dubai
because tanya is right now standing with
vladimir putin the trainer of yana
pomination who can maybe answer if
they're happy now with what what's
happening in the opening stage here
well that's the big question kai and of
course one e4 by magnus was a slight
surprise at least up in the play magnus
grip room
where t magnus is because i think
catalan was what everyone was expecting
a little more testing but the battle of
the openings continue and for more
insights we've got with us
long time trainer
uh feeling comfortable in such a big
match for him he definitely looked very
comfortable and finally tell us one
thing that on the rest day of course the
team is busy preparing tweaking
adjusting to what they've witnessed in
the first three games how involved was
jan himself in
this in-match progression of training
well it's
every player has his own recycle and
he's always flexible or when you feel
inspiration you are involved
he's definitely putting up an amazing
fight it's a great world championship
match between these two thank you so
much vladimir
thank you thank you
and that is team napomnacci clearly
doing all the right things that's
required to give us
a big fight at the world championship
match we do have a couple of moves and
magnus is continuing to blitz continuing
to play fast and just this last queen
move by white
again that wreaks to me of computer
preparation that's maybe not the most
human move normally we would be looking
to push pawns or develop pieces but
magnus moving a queen for the second
time
i'm trying to figure out the idea but
clearly there is one behind that and
napoli actually also reacting instantly
both players clearly within their
preparation i think he's doing maybe
some commentary for the friends of
jesus24 or he's just uh relaxing there
yeah black has taken the queens um just
before we show this as well some of the
viewers at home might have been
wondering in this position why okay
instead of white defending the queen why
why can't uh couldn't have grabbed a
pawn uh this would have been a huge
blunder unfortunately so white takes a
pawn but because of the tension between
the queens black would have been able to
play bishop takes pawn check giving away
the bishop but gaining time and then
after white recaptures the white queen
would have dropped off so we did indeed
see a trade of queens instead of this
magnus defending his queen the queen's
partying from the board and immediately
janna pogba actually pushes forward and
wow
magnus reacts again instantly so okay
and then we'll see the justification if
it's similar to everything we've been
saying now control the night circuit and
there you go the porn move is on the
board
yeah that was interesting napoli
actually we saw him fiddling with the
piece and then somehow he still managed
to make his move
without uh breaking that kind of
fidgeting routine
multitasking
meanwhile white has played a move not
the pawn move i was suggesting but a
similar idea just pushing that pawn two
squares forward and maybe just creating
a square for the white knight to jump
back to the square that that pawn used
to sit on
he
i mean he's not risking anything and he
seems to be in preparation so i think
he's so happy with this so young played
knight to d7 as we
as we said was logical
and
maybe this will be the first big long
thing we'll see from the pontiac because
it's a critical moment already maybe
yeah you know what i'm going to say
i know exactly where your physical
david's movement is
i'm going to push this pawn exactly
exactly well magnus played fast now so
that's nice at least bishop to f4 is
pretty surprising within but it's the
computer's top choice i have to say yeah
i think he just spent two minutes there
remembering and trying to work out what
happens next because i said there were
no forcing lines but this does initiate
some really forced moves right the world
championship match is pretty serious
business and uh he's not even turning
around numbers so i think today is all
about the chess game
we had a rest day yesterday he played
some football i think
he is enjoying himself hopefully certain
routine that must have been established
can you tell us a little bit about
a normal game day what's that like for
team magnus
well of course magnus wants to get up at
a certain point and then we need to
prepare some food and it's a bit
uncertain whether he wants one or two
meals and
he really wants to win
and speaking of really wanting to win
i'm sure this one has some good memories
to it
absolutely of course the first uh world
championship match is something unique
uh larger than life as i think i
mentioned
this was in chennai 2013 so looking at
it after
almost eight years
still brings up good memories it's like
yesterday
all right thank you so much henrik for
your time and uh yes that is
magnus's dad
with a sneak peek into magnus's life
outside the board
thank you so much tanya and it's really
nice to hear from henrik magnus he
really wants to win we had quite a few
moves on the board it's exactly what
david and aryan and ivanka took us
through but jan has been defending
extremely well against them
well there we have it grand master hunts
neiman breaking down the opening action
for us and we've got a move by magnus so
let's head over to the studio i kind of
pose black one or two uh questions to
answer there we go the first question
has been answered black's king runs away
from the check that's the only safe
square as well black's king needs to
defend some pawns and it puts the
pressure on the white knight
and that pawn cannot be taken as david
showed there is this fork
but jan is obviously not gonna gonna
fall for that he's probably gonna push
his a4 pawn magnus now made his move 98
he set some traps is the is this next
move sort of force for jana pomona
obviously has to move his king but could
he move it to another square not
repeating possibly
if
once a risk too far yeah he just wanted
to defend the uh the pawn on the f7
square that the white rook who's maybe
eyeing up so
yeah i'm debating playing as well but
it's going to be so cold there and it's
called here too it's called
we'll see we'll see here
yeah
but aaron we also know you you've been
seconding fanny giri for a while is that
something you will continue to do okay
we have an answer from magnus carlsen he
does not repeat okay he does not repeat
he does not go for the draw this is good
news great we still have some more
action um so he knows he needs to be
accurate napoli actually i'm slightly
surprised he spent so long spent seven
minutes there because this move uh
actually you called it a while ago aaron
is pretty much automatic right yeah it's
not clear what else black could have
done his rooks couldn't have been
improved the black knight couldn't move
and he needed to prevent the idea of the
white work on a1 joining in the game
because you know we saw that that was
failing by one move
yeah exactly and here you go race
initiated and then play on he does give
check ah the black king is going to much
forward and this will be the moment of
truth okay he goes and repeats the
position
okay
you're still in your chair yeah
so now the question arises okay he plays
for a win does push his pawn
now the now the big question comes okay
if minus is going to go for a draw well
we haven't seen anything better but
what could magnus have up his sleeve in
this particular position i mean is it to
trade works and just kind of
make a b line trade works how many
people
rookies are yeah there's there could be
that one as well also dropping the rope
back but i like this one let's try this
dropping the rook back
and hoping that after a trade that
run with
yeah head back or maybe just uh initiate
another race because after all the
knight is in a cage this black knight is
trapped this black king is also trapped
can't go for it now can i oh here he
comes okay it's a night check yeah this
one doesn't look like it's leading
anywhere either so
um night check are we about to see a
draw
if the black king goes back
magnus leaving the board there he will
probably just drop the knight back with
a check and we might well see a
repetition now then i realized i'm
winning and then i went from yarn
force to move uh
he has to move his king back and so the
question now for minus will he move his
knight back again
yeah there he goes
h8
okay actually
he played the check i think we're about
to see a draw but if jan does run away
from the draw knight c7 i think is a
good move and then threatening the rook
and the pawn f7 mm-hmm
okay so moment of truth if magnus
retreats his knight we're about to see a
draw and there we have it yeah so napoli
actually
he has to move his king forward that's
strictly the only move there we go he
stops the clock as if i mentioned he
doesn't make the move on the board he
stops it he tells the other it's about
to be three times and then we have the
handshake game four in dubai between
these two is another draw they are still
tied magnus carlsen and jana
magnus on his birthday with the white
pieces
this was not what he was hoping for
today